when I bought both well when I didn't
buy George's work initially but I was
part of the editorial team who was
pushing to buy a song of ice and fire
when it first came in as a trilogy and
we were actually as it was our fiction
Department and Christmas lunch
in fact when when the agent sent it
through to us we much wine was taken we
don't care however much it takes just by
it
it was very sneaky though because they
had the chunk that we got ended with
bran flops it's our how would we not
want to read all but originally that was
conceived of as a trilogy that was that
was how we saw it so did you have any
concept of just how fast the story arc
was going to be when you set out like
Magellan going round the world I I
didn't know I I thought it could be a
trilogy it was initially proposed to be
a game of Thrones a Dance with Dragons
and the winds of winter with three
initial titles there was a period here
where I thought I'd never get to a dance
with dragons the second book became the
third book and then it became the fourth
book and then it became the fifth book
but I definitely did get it out of the
fifth book and even then I didn't get
everything into it that I originally
thought where it was gonna be a trilogy
the tail grew in the telling fortunately
I'm being to come up with that wonderful
phrase it's all very well to discuss
some of these things in outline but then
when you actually sit down and write
them other thoughts occur to you
secondary characters come in you think
of an interesting subplot and suddenly
the stew is much richer but it also
takes more bowls to fill it up
you know ultimately I don't think it
matters artistically at least it
obviously matters to my publishers I
guess and to my fans but it doesn't
matter how many books it is because it's
one story yeah Lord of the Rings was not
a trilogy in any classic literary sense
dokyun didn't think he was writing a
trilogy he divided it into books but he
divided the six books that we note not
three
he broke thought he was writing one book
but it was so much longer than the other
books of the 1950s that his publisher
Allen & Unwin I believe decided they
would make it a trilogy and therefore
they set the template for fantasy
trilogies for the next 30 and you know
why they splitted into a trilogy
post-war paper prices were so high they
couldn't afford to print it as a 1500
page volume and here we are
fantasy trilogies rule it was a touched
on you about the underdogs in in both
your books and I just know it was that
an intentional thing that you wanted the
underdog to like to see you see you have
like Tyrion who hadn't best start in
life and fit but it just is something I
noticed especially like with aria as
well that they didn't have the best
start and they weren't probably the ones
that you thought would ever get anywhere
really but as the books progressed I
felt that they were the ones that seem
to be a thing stronger out of everyone
it's just my I think all of us feel like
we're underdogs so when you write a
character who starts out with a tough
time and has a harder start not only
does it let you develop their skills in
interesting ways with a dancing master
or a peculiar
mentor who's going to teach you to be an
assassin but I think you you win the
sympathy of everybody who's always if
everybody here has felt at one time or
another that everybody else in the world
had a better shot at things than they
did so when you engage that you engage
the reader and I think you create a
character that that brings the reader
more fully into the story yeah I have
always had a soft spot for the outsider
we need the underdog s you say cripples
bastards and broken things as the title
of one of the episodes it goes you know
they the angst or that they have in life
is is makes for more conflict makes for
more drama and there's something very
attractive about that I mean my my Game
of Thrones is full of full of outsiders
of all types we're all facing none of
them fit comfortably into the society at
which they've been born and they're all
struggling to find a place for
themselves in which they're valued and
loved and respected despite what their
society considers their their
deficiencies and out of that comes I
think good stories good stories